well i'm in charge of all the content
for the site so concierge com publishes
we views of hotels and restaurants and
activities and destinations around the
world so i've got a team of editors in
New York and then I've got a big network
of correspondents around the world who
are feeding us information so you know
here's a new hotel that opened in Paris
or here's the hot new nightclub in you
know Hong Kong so we take that content
we edit it we make it look good we put
it up on the website for people to use
that's part of my job and the other part
of my job is to develop the website in
de Joie more than just you know have
people reading reviews so you know we're
going to add the ability for people to
you know save the stuff they found on
concierge and create a trip itinerary
out of it and then share it with other
people or say they just got back from
you know a weekend in Montreal hey we
stayed at this great hotel we found this
great restaurant they'll be able to
upload that hotel a restaurant and share
it with the rest of the community so you
know the web changes every day and every
day I read about some new website that's
just starting up it's got some cool
technology or some some cool idea that
we think maybe we should try to do
something like that too so a large part
of my job is trying to figure out where
we steer the ship next
well the first thing to do is go to
concierge talk failing that you know
most people search everything these days
with Google right so you know people
Google in Paris trip ideas or berlin
hotels or New York restaurants and and
the land in a place like concierge will
they'll find you know expert
recommendations of things to do or
they'll land in a place that sells them
deals for those select types of trips
you know the land of plays like
TripAdvisor where you're seeing what
everyone else thinks of these places so
what we found in our own research and I
think bears out I think it's good advice
is people to shop around and that's
that's true when you're looking for
fares and it's true when you're looking
for ideas you know one of our challenges
as the business is to keep people coming
back to us remembering who we were and
and finding value and what we have to
offer that's that's greater than
everyone else has but we don't we're not
you know we're no illusion that they're
going to only use concierge calm and
they're planning a trip so you know we
try to you know make our offering just a
little bit more valuable to them but
knowing they're going to go elsewhere as
well
you